525 on a damp Wednesday morning got a
viewer email that prefers the temporary
fix at an East Valley signal where the
problem oh man they've had problems and
it's already tangled up that
intersection but soon it might not
matter anyway
Mac writes over the weekend the traffic
light at Charleston and Sacramento
stopped working and was operating as a
four-way stop well the flow of traffic
was so much better drivers taking their
turn no blocking of the intersection not
like what happens when the lights are
working in fact after the signal was
fixed it went back to being a blocked
intersection short tempers
why can't we go back to a four-way stop
well Mack it turns out that whichever
way works better at that intersection
right now an upcoming freeway access
change may make it a moot point here's
the deal starting early Monday you won't
be able to get to the north on 95 515
from Charleston
the Nevada Department of Transportation
says that access ramps going to be
rebuilt and it is not scheduled to
reopen until early April but you don't
have to be a junior traffic buddy to
know
with the Charleston on-ramp closed what
are your best freeway access options
well here you go coming from the south
there's Boulder Highway
heading toward Charleston from the
spaghetti Bowl there's Eastern
you know what go ahead and show off your
Junior traffic buddy badge spread the
driving you crazy message share the link
to this story at 8newsnow.com when you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down their phone enjoy the driving you
crazy conversation at traffic eight at
eightnewsnow.com